welcome to this video I'm playing the ex
just ax from Norway right yes alright so
let's see what opening we get ya played
lots of the Bogle because I write this
book about the opening but let's go for
something else just for the riot is sake
if he plays d 5 i'm intending to play a
blumenfeld gambit would be five but he's
hesitating her moment maybe he opts to
declined this invitation to the blue
moon felt on the Benoni and place 93 g3
one of those slow moves they're not bad
i mean a bit of a bit of a spoilsport
move because you surely longing for
fighters black and then then there's
some slow move plate but let's see
staking lots of time okay so let's play
the room hard gambit
yeah black intends to sacrifice a pawn
for a good Center so if white takes on e
6f take CC takes b5 it's a real gambit
black handsome given up on but has
established a nice center um I had
looked at this opening a while back but
um yeah I think I forgot most of what I
had looked at I'm not even sure about
the exact move order he takes a 6ft x e6
cb5 i think is it d 5 or as I think it's
a 6 actually a 6 takes and 95 yeah okay
need to figure that out when when he
actually plays it Oh something entirely
different I think here just before is
the right one and sending the night back
home so now should I just take yeah I
guess so and now it's it's like it been
only modern been only wear black has
some cut this movie 5 before for free on
the other hand I've weakened the c-4
square oh wait instead of d6 I should
have thought about Bishop d7 push a b7
sorry p7 attacking the porn
okay let's let's immediately kick the
bishop if he takes f6 Queen f6 I mean I
am attack v2 immediately
yeah the question is bishop h4 do i play
g5g five Bishop G 394 something like
that now maybe it's not a necessary
operation but maybe not bad yeah it's
really taking his sweet time here yeah I
know my time management okay so often
due to the side job of doing comments my
time management is also very
questionable that more than one occasion
but this is really taking it to extremes
it's not such a complicated position I
mean what what exactly is he thinking
about
if you play Bishop g5 in the first place
you should have some idea what to do
against h6 because it's just the most
natural move okay he retreats um okay I
could go G 594 it's not bad
yeah come on I'm just here this grabs
the bishops and Bishop g7 of course the
next move it's a bit slow of course but
cannot have it all the drawback of all
this is of course at c4 is a week square
a night there would be in quite quite an
annoyance but some of course I'm again
space and check yeah I wasn't sure this
helping this is really helping him say
here probably now I'm exchange on on d7
wait wait I could I can't think about 97
97 is not bad at all the night could be
nicely placed on b6 taking d fire fear
let's do that it's actually better
so now i will just take it and night to
be 6 cm this was the idea why not Queen
f 6m Queen f6 would have been good
stupid okay but I can play g4 and Queen
f 61 immediately Queen f6 is called e5
the thing about Queenie of success he
cannot defend be too I just win this and
this probably wins the game so what I'm
getting at is I can play this move just
attack the night and then play going to
have six and now I don't see how a
defense be too he can play Knight f5 but
I'd still just take be 297 Queen g7 at
the end a one is lost
I think like wind snow just like that
it's just be too I'd at the end there's
always a rope hanging so probably yeah
yeah probably need to play 92 now give
up be too but at the end up late bishop
see 3 i'm just a pawn up and yeah my can
take here and 97 Queen g7 that's a one
hanging had no way to protect the rook
in the corner I can just take it check
okay the only only idea left young
so just
run away with the king if we take c5 I
intended to just play um kingi aid no
way he is going to is going to save the
rukon a one Quincy seven Ruger they'd
just play it simple but I can also play
Quincy one at some point let's say
Quincy seven book f-89 Queen takes sm
there's also the screen see one with
yeah there's this threat in yeah I guess
it is just play here this is the
simplest way if it takes a seven now I
can play Quincy one checking into Queen
tags h1 and he loses or already has lost
the h1 rogue and a one look is also not
defensible
yeah he doesn't really have a booth
the queen is also relatively quickly
back helping with defense so I can take
a one and immediately go back to f6 35
to coordinate defenses
yeah this is the bad side of 15 minutes
yes sometimes it's a one side being in a
rather busted position and then taking
ages to resign or continue it's a it's
just a gone gone game with the rook on a
one loss
ok rookies look not the most
revolutionary thing to say but it's
nevertheless true
okay I wonder what's the easiest stem
way now yeah maybe maybe this one
getting rid of the d6 night this is the
only active piece that might return to
f5
yeah okay k King h7 is really bad
shouldn't do that Brooke hmm the rook
doesn't have a great square let's go
here so if he attacks it again I can
play Queen a2 and cover it at least the
Queen only seven is not I mean it's
blocking the deep on oh I can actually
let's go check on deform
come on let's check give the give the
Queen some lumion default with the tempo
rook f2 looks ridiculous so King King
moves and after that maybe just h5 also
allowing for look h6 yeah this is good
it's good also threatens h4 of course
yeah so this should be decisive actually
h4
using the h8 rook on its original square
ya know move freely h4s absolutely
crushing
so still h4 cannot be bad opening up to
this rock
check
yeah he takes the only move and jump
maybe just here Jack can you have to
look a two so nice and F form all right
check should be should be quite good
with temple and this is my next move
Jack can enter the look F to Queen have
to pre move from eight
quite resigned yeah I'd started out with
a strange opening and you spend so much
time here so here not only white girls
Bishop g5 or you can actually take the
pawn both interesting this I think helps
black to lose two moves here and here
here maybe we should be seven as an idea
and I played my moves a bit quick just
attacking this they're probably some
ways for why to make a good sack out of
it like like this one could be well
right okay in the game this was played
and here I think black am is quite
comfortable already maybe maybe this one
is better I don't know check check this
already is tricky how do you ever
protect this with Queen f6 coming adhere
of course Queen f6 is the way to go I
only saw this right after I played this
this was the original idea so I played
it but not a queen f6 is just much
better night here after Queen f6 he's
got a five which is not terrible but ok
it's not necessary i can played in this
way and also will be too and this
basically just wins the game he has got
no way to to defend this alright thanks
for watching